talking about Langton Zandt which is a
really interesting kind of conceptual
idea that someone's had it's an example
of what's called a cellular automaton
hello hello tiny dog it's a different
person it's sorry about that
interworking langton Zandt
is an example of what's called a
cellular automaton so it's a bit like a
game of life so you've got a grid of
squares the squares change color
depending on what's going on in the
thing in the game of life it's slightly
different because the whole thing has a
set of rules and everything changes at
the same time but in Langton Zant there
is a specific there's an aunt that lives
on the grid and it walks from square to
square and as it moves it changes what
the squares are doing and it's an
example of something which has a very
simple rule but ends up being really
really complex so this is a Brid grid of
squares and I guess show me tell me how
you made it shows people hair secrets
okay well I got a paper bag and cut one
side of it and then I print it onto that
and it didn't break my printer which I
was very happy about and then I've
laminated that so I can rubber if
there's the handles off the paper bag
it's simple rules basically see start
off with a completely blank grid that
looks nothing like an ant I'll give it
another couple of legs there we go
so essentially what he does every turn
is he either turns left 90 degrees or
turns right 90 degrees steps forward and
changes the color of the square as he
leaves and it did what he does depends
on what color the square is on is so if
you starts off on a white square he will
turn 90 degrees to the right and step
forward so I'll be over here and as he
leaves that Square it will change it
from white to black so that's now a
black square now he's on a white square
so he will turn right again and he'll
end up on this square facing this way
and he will change that Square to black
as well and then he'll keep doing that
so we'll move TURN RIGHT from there and
end up here facing that way and he will
change that one to black and this is
where it starts getting interesting
because now he turns right and goes back
onto that first square against he's now
on there facing that way and you can't
quite see him if he's on a black square
and turn left
so you'll now come off this way and go
this way and as he leaves that square e
changes it from black back to white
again
so essentially you can keep moving like
this
as long as you like and just continue
changing what happens on the on the
board and if you start with a completely
blank square it's kind of interesting so
he will start off by making quite simple
patterns and kind of things that look a
bit symmetrical sometimes but all kind
of fairly simple fairly self-contained
after a few hundred steps he starts to
just become more chaotic and eventually
what he's doing look completely random
and you're thinking is this just going
to carry on like this forever
and when he gets to it's something like
10,000 steps it's just a number a bit
more than 10,000 he suddenly becomes
completely regular so he will start
doing like a column of diagonal column
of things that moves off words it's like
a hundred and four step cycle that
repeats and just continues moving him
diagonally off off to one corner and
you'll carry on to infinity doing that
and it's what's called an attractor so
this this diagonal column that he does
is something that you will always end up
doing like they've tried loads of
different initial States loads of
different ways of setting up the board
to start with he always ends up
eventually getting to this weird
diagonal column thing and just carries
on doing that forever and I just love
that that it's like a thing that he's
drawn to do
you
you can start with any grade you want so
you can almost program it like a
computer because you know that it will
do you know whatever it was going to do
given the particular starting
configuration and I think it's about two
thousand someone discovered that you can
actually use this to run any computer
program so you can build kind of
computer logic gates and that kind of
thing within this system and it is a
universal Turing machine